foreign
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
foreign
yeah you tell me let's let's get into it
then let's get into it also uh brother
side asked what did you guys think of
hijab and Peterson stay tuned for uh our
reaction inshallah drop tonight or
tomorrow
um but without further Ado let's jump
right into it guys smash that like
button this is that clock here for
always tuning in and uh let's go right
into it Bismillah
I will do that again
basically it was taken out of context
that clip I don't know if you've seen
the original stream but I was actually
reacting to acts of Haram I was at I was
reacting towards people who are walking
around with their dicks out people at
Pride parades Western women acting like
hoes and so in response I was doing uh
mocking the Muslim prayer sound
can you explain to me why that's
disrespectful it was like protective
quality so when someone is
talking bad about the religion or
they're mocking you or they're doing
something like that they are very quick
to stand their ground and say what they
got to say which
you know a lot of times it could be seen
as a bad thing but in reality like look
at all the other religions
like they're they don't stand for
anything so in essence it's a bad thing
but it's also a good thing
now for anyone that doesn't know this
was a stream that we did right with
Brothers Nico a few weeks ago
um in this stream
um for those of you that haven't seen
the links in the description we very
clearly went over like you know Islamic
disrespect and why you know when you get
a little bit of heat from the Muslims
after mocking them why it's not the same
as other religions and that's what
brother Angel was trying to outline that
it's not that we're you know tyrannical
or anything like that we just have very
low tolerance when it comes to
disrespect because we really believe in
what we believe in now a few days later
he went on a stream with Destiny and
this is what happened
and one of the clips was of Nick Fuentes
going off about some stuff and then uh
sneak on the back singing and dancing
yeah
hold on right no rule for you you are
not allowed to make fun of any religions
on my stream until you make fun of Islam
after you do that you're free to make
fun of whatever you want okay look at
his face look at his face
I want you to get that [ __ ] on stream
okay I want you to get that shutter
stream then you can go and choose that
same energy but unless you're willing to
do that
none of that [ __ ]
they're not going to come for us they're
going to come for you you never I am
never joking about Islam again I learned
my lesson [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no but isn't it isn't that you
self-censoring yeah oh yeah goes Andrew
Tay 2.0 okay he's ready for twitlongers
he's not ready for fot was all right
okay Hillary
so we'll pause it right there before we
continue but what are your thoughts
he said and he's not ready for twit
mongers but he's ready for sorry he's
ready for tweet mongers but he's not
ready for fatwas
um I'm gonna be honest first and
foremost
someone said Destiny's Child I agree I
think Destiny's Child I think that was
too harsh
um I but I don't think he's he's trying
to encourage and make fun of Islam I
think he's trying to point out the fact
that he will disrespect anyone and
everyone except Muslims which obvious
Muslims we think is okay great but at
the same time
we shouldn't we should encourage him
basically to respect all religions and
not make fun of everyone even as Muslims
we're taught not to make fun of other
people's Gods even if they're false
idols and stuff right we're taught not
to distract other people's ways and
lives and and use you know harsh words
and harsh uh tones even with people so
we should encourage that as well with
with people like sneak on others uh so I
think what Destiny's getting an overall
is a good message did he do it in a good
way no hell no but this is this is just
what it's like in this trip but that's
that's my general thoughts what do you
guys think what about you
no I mean rather you put in a good way
bro I wasn't even thinking it was like
that I was just thinking of like how
disrespectful it was but then the way
you put it man it just makes sense
but it reminds me a lot about like you
know when you go to Netflix bro it's
like everyone's trying to like get away
with saying things about Islam that's
one thing I noticed like in Netflix they
had a girl you know fasting for Ramadan
right and she was gonna break her fast
and they handed her you know like a shot
of alcohol
and before taking it she literally said
Bismillah
and it's like I can't help but parallel
that Destiny thing with you know Netflix
and the media because these people have
been trying to like really get away with
disrespecting Islam and they do it in
the most like subtle ways possible they
do it in the most seemingly organic ways
as possible but these things are all
premeditated bro you know no
yeah that's fair I mean I I think it
depends on his intention right because
something like that to me is just not
clear right it you could you could look
at it and say and that was my
interaction by the way you could look at
it and say okay he intentionally just
dislikes Islam and he wants to basically
cause problems right but you could also
say that he used that moment of snico
making fun of uh you know Jews which
again is messed up you know he shouldn't
do that
um and he wanted to capitalize and say
you're willing to make fun of everyone
else but not Muslims why is that the
case so again I don't I don't think
Destiny in this case had you know ill
intent but at the same time you're
definitely right because there was
something that was disrespectful against
this time he could have phrased it in
the sense that you know why are you
willing to mock Jews and other people
you're not willing to mock Muslims he
didn't have to say you he didn't have to
say mock everyone including Muslims he
should have said uh don't mock anyone
you don't mock Muslims don't mock anyone
else but I think this is this is how
streaming is bro this is what gets the
clips this is what gets more attention
that's probably why he said it like that
which we don't encourage At All by the
way we don't encourage yeah true
making fun of the same Islamic prayer
like two weeks ago on fresh and fit vlog
bro if this is real he almost on on the
three Muslims on IG but he wouldn't I
thought he would honestly I don't think
he got I thought he would make anything
yeah and I just want to throw in here
like
it's it's a certain truth that in in
streams this is how people act so they
they play a character to be able to get
like you know the views and all that
stuff but it's like
oh bro like
I just feel like that that just it's so
you're against yourself at that point if
you're you're doing something just for
views like you're not even being real to
yourself
and like this bro like just think about
Islam bro in Islam we're talking what
with uh
what's up man it's and like you see
these people on the streams like
that's non-existent it's not bro
they generally do things knowing it'll
get backlash but they're willing to like
make a controversy and like apologize
and do all this you know what I mean
like I feel like I can see in some of
their eyes they know what their actions
are going to do tomorrow but they're
like let me just do it anyway you know
but again Miller got them and uh we set
apart
um somebody commented uh this is
pre-recorded don't cop boys or don't cap
I don't bro here's the thing if it's
pre-recorded I don't know how we're
going back in time man I don't know man
we gotta be super skilled bro to like
react to you guys in the future bro I
don't know how we're doing that you tell
me bro
someone kept uh talking about the this
one
Daniel already uh dunked on Destiny in
the debate so apparently Daniel
hakikachu had a debate with Destiny yeah
yeah you guys want us to react to that
inshallah we will but uh let's keep
going I could already tell it's not good
just thinking about it bro that's it
just doesn't even sound like it would be
good yeah yeah I watched it actually
sorry I know you want to react to it but
you watched it
we'll talk about it and I don't think
it's worth us worth it for us to
reactive to be completely honest uh
maybe some clips some parts but it's it
wasn't anything grand
um and from the very beginning I was
like okay I see where this is going
because
imagine in a debate you have a whole 10
15 20 minutes to convince your opponent
in the audience of your side you know
any debate people love talking over each
other that stuff you have a whole 10 20
minutes just to give your opening
statement and try and convince everyone
of your argument Destiny completely
omitted his full opening statement and
said let's just go straight to q a back
and forth
and he just continued to try and press
and ask questions like would you do you
think that you know
the alpha alphabetized people will be
happier under Islamic rule he's like
he's asking about one specific
subsection of people and you know living
in the west he's like would they be
happy and it's it is it's a mess in my
opinion to be completely honest
um
[Music]
hmm
someone's still commenting bro how did
you read this bro we're just joking this
is live stream cool I know
oh man subhanallah
um bro apparently there's a lot of
comments um and I heard this in one of
the debates with snico too that
Destiny's an open relationship bro
you know he's
he's letting his girl do whatever bro
with anyone and I'm pretty sure he is
too you know but
what do you what are you gonna what dawa
the destiny would you have to say about
leader bro that's come on bro that's
isn't that Cocoa Tree even as a
non-muslim bro he should feel something
yeah come on bro come on man listen to
come on man come on bro
these things are like you know fitro bro
this innate sense of like protective
jealousy
and you're just suppressing it to make
her happy bro
I've probably heard it like a bit too
many times like oh you gotta not be
jealous you you gotta let your girl do
her thing you know if she's going to the
club with her girls like you should you
should be hanging out with your friends
you should be doing this and you
shouldn't be wearing like
I think you should you should trust her
yeah you should trust her bro are you
insecure
bro listen whether you're ever a Muslim
or not whether you're having Islam or
not like
you should never be in an open
relationship bro
you're a woman I don't think a woman
would ever see you as like
top like Daddy like Alpha I don't think
she'll ever see you as that if she's
over here with other men
um because it's it's in women's nature
to see one
man as that yeah and when she sees one
man as that oh she's gonna do whatever
she can to like spend as much time with
this man as possible
hmm
yeah we talk a little bit about this in
the episode with uh brother Gabriel that
you guys are gonna see in a few days the
in-person studio podcast we talked about
polygyny and we talked about polyandry
and why that doesn't work one woman with
multiple men and we really wanted on
that inshallah so stay tuned for that
around me anything else before we are
gone
and now just you know all these things
that these people are doing you know
these are symptoms of basically living
in the west these are symptoms of a
progressed and by progressed I don't
mean in a positive way just over time
evolved liberal secular liberal Society
it's not something that is good it's not
something that's that's it's something
that's very demeaning actually and I
promote a lot of demeaning things and
people will always tell you you know do
what you want as long as you're not
hurting others but uh by definition
um you're they allow you to hurt
yourself
and if people are allowing you to hurt
yourself then basically they're allowing
the hurt of others to occur so it's all
a mess it's all
fallacious it's all sad and if people
actually want to live a complete proper
life submit to Allah
submit to our great it sounds crazy to
people just think about it the one who
created you
right and gave you life
liberalism didn't do that the one who
created you and gave you life he created
you so you can worship him so you can
obey him so you can submit to him so you
can live life according to what he says
and you go off and you you basically
take whatever Pleasures you have and you
try and relieve yourself with them
fulfilling life you will die one day and
call us you know that's it
yeah but people people actually take
offense to that like we tell someone
you're like you're probably your purpose
in this life is to worship the Creator
like they'll be like what like that's
that's my purpose and uh like my purpose
is to uh be this business owner my
purpose is to be this like this
celebrity my purpose is to be this
professional athlete or something like
this but I'll tell you some crazy stuff
but it's
I don't know again people take offensive
because I myself I took offense to it
when I was a Muslim yeah and that's
where you just have to explain I won't
spend too long but this is what where
you just have to explain subjective
purpose uh versus objective purpose and
you know why you actually exist versus
why you want to continue to exist where
you find meaning in life and what is the
meaning of life these are like very very
different things and someone can be
obviously a Muslim and a business owner
and they could use that business you
know to do good and then you can kind of
use whatever they're doing to inspire
them shallots come to Islam
um but to each their own you know you're
right because you can't just give a
blanket statement to everyone and it's
sad because on the podcast you kind of
have to you have to give blanket
statements to everyone uh there's one
person that needs to hear this another
person that needs to hear that and some
person needs to hear the same message
just slightly variated so they
understand it in the context of their
life better and I heard something you
know really really kind of tremendous
recently
he was asked about Islam
he just gave the Five Pillars when he
was asked about Iman he gave the six
pillars of Iman worship Allah basically
believe in Allah in the angels and books
and The Messengers and the destiny in
the day of judgment and so on and so
forth now that not Destiny like this guy
but because
a decree from Allah
he didn't go into all these little
tangents and specific things and because
that's too much for people he gave six
very basic ones because his people they
didn't have you know super progressed
philosophical thought or anything like
that gave them what they needed and
that's something that we need to focus
on so that's a good point on hold your
duck Locker I don't know man was that a
new t-shirt bro
I've had this t-shirt bro I wore it
don't you remember when we were in Kenny
bro maybe maybe I should notice these
things more
come on Romney remembers this
Romney's like I've never seen that in my
life yeah I'm sorry bro I don't remember
it maybe it's the lighting oh Mom bro
you you complimented it the day I wore
it you're like oh that's a nice t-shirt
is it the long one
it's it's like the lime green one it
doesn't matter bro I remember this
doesn't even matter bro
it doesn't even matter bro
um subhanallah okay so we'll go back
into it I'm gonna rewind it a bit like
30 seconds for the people that just
joined
um and then I'll just let it play till
the end inshallah
Fuentes going off about some stuff and
then uh snico in the back singing and
dancing
hold on right no rule for you you are
not allowed to make fun of any religions
on my stream until you make fun of Islam
after you do that you're free to make
fun of whatever you want okay look at
his face look at his face
take time
they're not gonna come for us they're
going to come for you you never I am
never joking about Islam again I learned
my lesson [ __ ] no
[ __ ] now
isn't that you self-censoring yeah goes
Andrew Tay 2.0 okay he's ready for
twitlongers he's not ready for fat wise
all right
okay Hillary
[ __ ] out I mean you know listen I think
there's pretty it's fine you know what I
mean just just do your thing sneako I
want you to be happy and free
no no that's it I don't have anything to
joke about Islam it's a perfect religion
ex-muslim bro they don't even like you
look at you getting out all your hate
for the fact that they call you a fake
uh what are you Ethiopians
I 100 I'm a proud you got excommunicated
from the [ __ ] religion so now you go
call me how can you get excommunicated I
don't know you kill me they don't they
don't jack me no more bro
you're acting like I ran up on the
mosque and they're like nah you're too
you refuse your ID like no I I just
don't believe and I've always said this
on YouTube videos and I say all the time
they never come for me what Muslims
coming from
I'm coming for you I don't know man
there were probably 11 dudes and Charlie
hebdo a place that were like we're good
I've actually made videos critiquing
um a few Arabic cultures and uh Muslim
practices before and I never had any
issues so I'm straight okay you know
what's funny bro I've watched a couple
of the videos too where he critiques
Arab cultures and like and literally
none of them have anything to do with
Islam bro
yeah listen I don't know who this guy is
right I don't know who he is I think you
showed it was like a bar or Ada and
something right yeah let's invite him to
come talk we invite you to come talk not
harshly not fight not to come and attack
you about leaving his time whatever we
invite you to come talk about Islam
if you really loved Islam and you're and
you're sure that Islam is false and
stuff okay come talk to us Insha'Allah
yeah and don't worry about like
Muslims
at your neighbor coming after you I
think that's at least you could probably
worry about someone though
a little bit more Grand scale things man
whether you believe in that
um someone also asked um
what do you guys think of hassanabi he's
a political streamer Muslim that wears
nail polish Etc and someone also
commented uh he's not Muslim but again
that's not really for us to judge but
what do you guys think about that
I actually have kind of an opinion on
him so if you guys have one go insha
Allah if not then I'll jump in
um
um
I
so how do I say this I don't
I think he's a people pleaser to be
honest I think he's the people pleaser
to a very specific segment of society
right
I I think that a lot of the time he will
say things just to kind of make a group
of people happy which is not necessarily
always a bad thing because for some
people it does provide kind of like a
safe space you know someone you can
watch or you can you know trust it isn't
you know crazy or anything like that and
it's very like opposing to people like
Andrew Tay some people really like they
feel like they need that right
but at the same time when it comes to
Islam and he does do things and say
things that are kind of off-putting like
he'll like you know smash capitalism and
that stuff which is great but I don't
think he actually understands what Islam
is as a Dean as a full you know a way of
life system of Life something that
encompasses everything that you do
and I think it shows in the way that he
talks about
you know um politics and that stuff
because he's talking about politics
purely from a a an unislamic perspective
a politically an Islamic perspective so
you know if it was me in his position
you know I would never talk about kind
of you know why why this ism is good
here and that isn't as good there and
and so on and so forth and smash one on
Islamic way of life with another
honestomic way of life I would just
basically smash them all using Islam
itself
um and I would never wear a nail polish
either I wouldn't be like when it's just
haunted regime I I may Allah guide him I
don't think he's an insincere guy I mean
um I mean I mean but I do think he's
kind of a people pleaser if I'm being
honest
um okay I'm the lover no that I've seen
it all bro I I've I had no idea who
hasanabi is bro you used to talk about
him every now and then when we do like a
private call or you would bring some
relevant points up you know but I never
seen him myself I've never come across
him until there was this video I saw on
the YouTube algorithm saying I made
Andrew Tate run away from a debate
something like that you know and then I
clicked on it and there was this debate
between Andrew Tate and asanabi and I
don't know bro it looks like it was kind
of like just a trap that was set up you
know and he knew exactly what to say to
get catch Andrew off guard but there was
no validity in a lot of the points that
he was bringing up but that's just me
well I I saw I mean I don't know what
which clip because I think he came on
two or three days in a row so I I saw a
few parts of it the part that I saw
um I actually think was fairy because he
was talking about anecdotal experience
versus empirical evidence
and I think I think yeah I think all of
his hands points in that were completely
Fair the other ones I don't really
remember someone comment on those but
that was the one that I watched and to
be fair I think 100 Hassan was right
you have a question yeah
if a girl paints some news
she can't make would do if she has
painted nails right until she depends on
it depends on the type of nail polish
too because again we can't give you
photos at least for me and I'll let
Romney go too but they have made some
water permeable nail polishes that a lot
of Scholars is okay because the point
that I will do is for the water to reach
your nail beds um but there's a lot of
um basically there's a lot of uh other
you know they're like how is it even
possible because if it's nail polish you
know it's not gonna you know but a lot
of the ones that are water permeable
they don't last it's like two three days
in they'll just watch interesting yeah
because I was gonna say something
about like him with the nail polish and
like his we do not being like acceptable
but like let me just stop because I
obviously like I'm I'm far out of like
my lane and that so
yeah I've I've seen him you know saying
stuff like LG TV lives matter and this
and that of course we're not we're not
anti their lives matter you know what I
mean like we're not here saying they
should be off the bro they should be
deleted you know in the west you know
but in terms of us you know disagreeing
with the practices their morality their
version of love we don't agree with the
the slightest bro and there's a lot of
people you know you'll see ilhan Omar
and all these people you know we don't
agree with it but at the end of the day
these are people that are here
um they are identifying as Muslim you
know whether or not they're Muslim or
not it's not up to us three at all it's
up to Allah but they do come across as
Muslim and I also think a lot of them do
have a big part to play in why the west
and at least society as a whole has
gotten this upper hand into like
humiliating Muslims and making us you
know out to be like these evil forces
because there's such a discrepancy in
like how much we stand up for the truth
versus how much other Muslims don't and
I feel like a lot of politicians and a
lot of people if they were and Gabriel
talks about this a lot is essentially we
have failed Society in a way we let them
get to the point where you know they
think that they can put you know gay
hijabis and all this stuff for Allah on
Netflix because we haven't put our foot
down and we didn't you know stand our
ground when it was time
yeah yeah there was there was a huge I
think era when like our our you know the
generations that came before us whether
our parents or their parents love Adam
but there was a long time where people
were not practicing they were not
speaking up I'm talking about look at
like a good amount of people right
because they didn't have three random
Muslims that can get on a podcast and
start talking about Islam you know they
didn't have things like that so you know
the propaganda they were propaganda
doesn't and all Muslims you know do what
they did about Islam and so on and so
forth and Islam just wasn't really
widespread so anything
um I don't I won't even say that I had a
misconception I'll just say they didn't
know I don't know if they had a
misconception but at least at the very
least it probably didn't even really
know about Islam because people are
talking about it people are practicing
and preaching uh and it's only nowadays
with the internet and everything
people say that you know internet works
kind of a favor of shaytan because of
things that you know is put up on it I
agree I agree but at the same time we
could utilize it to to spread a step and
I think that's why a lot of young people
are coming and realizing that Sam's the
truth and they were coming very kind of
they have like this this Zeal in the
beginning and then they want to start
their Channel I've had many brothers
come to me and say I want to start my
Tick Tock I want to start my YouTube I
want to start a channel uh and I
encourage all of them to inshallah
inshallah
oh man may love bless you bro every
every time someone comes up to me and
tells me they want to start a YouTube
channel I tell them don't do it why not
I'm just playing I'm just playing
there's kind of some truth in there
today it's like it's I forgot who said
it bro that's not what you think it's
not what you think that's what I'll say
yeah one of the one of the chefs that we
got on the on the platform he said that
Fame is a necessary evil
so be careful if you if you need to get
famous to you know for like a greater
good yeah someone wrote I can get in
touch with or in contact with Abel helps
up set this up insha Allah bro if you
can insha Allah reach out to us at the
three Muslims on Instagram
um
you know and inshallah we'll make it
happen bro but we will wrap this one up
Insha'Allah for all the people smiling
the comments with the Jordan Peterson uh
response inshallah you will see this uh
either tonight or tomorrow insha Allah
um but without further Ado and Ami you
want to end it off there's nothing else
to say
and with that being said